judge a man by his questions
rather than by his answers
a person is worth something
only when he has his own point of view
an explain joke
is no longer a joke
life is a shipwreck
but we must not forget to sing in the
lifeboats
those who can make you believe
absurdities
can make you commit atrocities
the more i read
the more i acquire
the more
certain i am
that i know nothing
the comfort of the rich depends upon an
abundant supply of the poor
to give out someone else's secret
is a betrayal
to give out yours is stupidity
may god defend me from my friends
i can defend myself
from my enemies
love truth
but pardon error
i have never made but one prayer to god
a very short one
o lord make my enemies ridiculous
and god granted it
i don't know where i'm going
but i am on my way
god is a comedian playing to an audience
that is too afraid to laugh
fools have a habit of believing that
everything written by a famous author is
admirable
for my part i read only to please myself
and like only what suits my taste
every man is guilty of all the good he
did not do
dare to think for yourself
despite the enormous quantity of books
how few people read
and if one reads profitably
one would realize how much stupid stuff
the vulgar herd is content to swallow
every day
the most important decision you make
is to be in a good mood
doubt is an uncomfortable condition
but certainty
is a ridiculous one
the secret of being a boar is to tell
everything
cherish those who seek the truth but
beware of those who find
it it is better to risk saving a guilty
person
than to condemn an innocent one
think for yourself and let others enjoy
the privilege of doing so too
faith consists in believing what reason
cannot
appreciation is a wonderful thing
it makes what is excellent in others
belong to us as well
every man is a creature of the age in
which he lives
and few are able to raise themselves
above the ideas of the time
our wretched species is so made that
those who walk on the well-trodden path
always throw stones at those
who are showing a new road
the human brain is a complex organ
with the wonderful power of enabling man
to find reasons for continuing to
believe whatever it is
that he wants to believe
prejudices are what fools use for reason
we never live
we are always in the expectation of
living
don't think money does everything
or you are going to end up doing
everything for money
the art of medicine consists of amusing
the patient
while nature cures the disease
perfect
is the enemy of good
the longer we dwell on our misfortunes
the greater is their power to harm us
the only way to comprehend what
mathematicians mean by infinity
is to contemplate the extent of human
stupidity
our labor preserves us from three great
evils
weariness
vice
and want
it is with books as with men
a very small number play a great part
one day everything will be well
that is our hope
everything's fine today
that is our illusion
the happiest of all lives
is a busy solitude
history never repeats itself
man always does
behind every successful man
stands a surprised mother-in-law
to succeed in the world it is not enough
to be stupid
one must also be polite
i would rather obey a fine lion much
stronger than myself
than 200 rats of my own species
if a lady says
no
it means maybe
if she says maybe
it means yes
if she says yes
it's not a lady
[Music]
one great use of words
is to hide our thoughts
to hold a pen is to be at war
it is hard to free fools from the chains
they revere
opinions have caused more ills than the
plague or earthquakes on this little
globe of ours
each player must accept the cards life
deals him
or her
but once they are in hand
he or she alone must decide how to play
the cards
in order to win the game
think how difficult it is to change
yourself
and you will understand how
insignificant your opportunities are
to change others
how many stupid things people say just
out of a desire to say something
the strength of a woman
lies in the weaknesses of men
a person must dream in order to see the
meaning of life
you